tension on the streets of myanmar this
week as the country braces for a
possible political crisis
we're not saying the military will take
power but we're not saying it won't
either
this was the moment that it all began in
a press conference on tuesday
military spokesperson zormin tun refused
to rule out the possibility of a coup
the following day military chief minang
lang stoked fears when he said the
constitution should be repealed if it
was not abided by
the comments follow weeks of complaints
from the military of voter fraud in
november's election
and demands for an investigation the
military is forcing the uec and the
government that hey no no
you can't just ignore us you know we are
the stakeholder
we have obligations
uh we are the guardian to the
constitution so
so this is a major message the military
is trying to send it to the
government and also the international
communities
fear escalated after reports of an
increasing security presence
and sightings of armoured vehicles being
moved around various cities
as tensions reached their peak on
saturday the military issued a new
statement saying the
commander-in-chief's comments had been
misinterpreted
but just hours later emboldened by
rumors hundreds of protesters gathered
in yangon at a pro-military rally
where speeches welcomed a coup with
support of the people
protests like this have been happening
on an almost daily basis over the last
few weeks
while they have been gaining attention
they failed to draw the numbers
for what would be considered a show of
popular support
but this crowd is gaining confidence
and it's stoking fear in the community
as the pressure builds there have been
violent attacks on nld supporters
watching on the nld say
accusations of voter fraud are just
being used as an excuse to sow fear
senior general minong lang is making the
nld scared and making the people scared
his main intention is to extend his
senior general position
military chief minang lang is due to
retire in july and may be fearful of
losing power
although imminent action from the
military now appears less likely tension
remains high as relations between the
civilian government and the military
reach an all-time low ali fal al jazeera
yangon